e no ano novo vem muita gente pra casa
da gente a mãe da gente chega pra gente
e fala assim olha você arrume seu quarto
que seus parentes vão vir PR cá amanhã
viu eu acho engraçado porque eu vou na
casa dos meus parentes eles não arruma
as coras para eu chegar não eu acho a
coisa engraçada na mãe do po porque é o
seguinte se ela manda você arrumar e
você não arruma quando chega os parentes
ela gosta de fazer um tour pela casa
mostrando todas as reformas que ela fez
olha aqui mulher aqui era uma parede que
a gente derrubou aí a gente fez uma
divisa aqui em cima a gente não colocou
até em cima que aí a gente liga a luz
fica a mesma luz pro quarto de cá e pro
quarto de lá né mulher para economizar
aí chega no seu quarto ela começa a
ficar ali difamando PR as pessoas vem cá
comad aqui é o quarto do in ó aqui on ó
como é que fica as coisas ó ó ó ó aqui ó
é que tem camisa tá vendo esse menino é
um seboso com